another overnight israeli incursion in
ramallah on the west bank
met by more stone throwing youths
soldiers responded with
live fire one palestinian man was found
shot dead
on the roof of a building there and
another was killed in nablus
as the palestinian death toll rises
israel's prime minister benyamin
netanyahu was unapologetic
our forces are behaving in the manner
necessary for their self-defense
and occasionally there are fatalities or
wounded on the palestinian side
as a result of our forces self-defense
actions
palestinian officials are warning that
israel's tactics will only escalate the
already tense situation
this is one more crime to add to
netanyahu's record the palestinian
people will oppose the israeli
occupation
we'll escalate the popular resistance in
all palestinian cities
villages and refugee camps against this
occupation
israel has made it clear that while
looking for the three missing teenagers
it is also seeking to strike a blow
against hamas
the islamic militant group has welcomed
the kidnapping without claiming
responsibility for it
the three boys have been missing for 10
days now there has still been no sign of
their whereabouts or any ransom demand